[Music]
hello and welcome to deer hike a job nor
as I prefer to think of it Dear John and
Hank it's a comedy podcast where me and
my brother John answer your questions
give you dubious advice and bring you
all the week's news from both Mars and
AFC Wimbledon how you doing John
I'm doing well I'm just back from
northern Jordan where I spent the last
few days visiting refugee camps and
Syrian refugees who are living in cities
in Jordan most of the over 600,000
refugees from the Syrian war living in
Jordan are living not in camps but in
cities but it was a fascinating trip
very emotionally exhausting at times
very very difficult but also I feel
really really lucky to have been able to
go and to have been able to hear some of
the stories of refugees their families
and and also stories from people living
in Jordan about you know how the refugee
crisis has reshaped their country since
10% of all people living in Jordan right
now are Syrian refugees more than a
quarter of people living in Lebanon
right now are Syrian refugees the scope
of the problem is is truly overwhelming
and I think it was really important to
me to be able to go there to get a human
sense of it you know to be able to see
it not in terms of hundreds of thousands
and millions and big statistics but
instead in terms of actual people that
is fantastic and I am really impressed
that you did it you sound a little bit
ill are am I making that up no no you're
not I am
ill I drank a lot of tap water and chai
and coffee in in the camps
you know when families offer you food
and and water and tea it's important to
say yes especially because you know
these are people who in many cases are
only have about 70 cents
per day for food and other necessities
and so you know they're sharing that
with you is really important but of
course the water is not not always super
clean I also ate some delicious falafel
sandwiches with pita bread at the
Zaatari refugee camp and might have
gotten sick from that but I also had an
amazing pizza at Ed's a three so I could
have gotten sick from that and I had a
falafel sandwich at the ass rock refugee
camp so I could have gotten sick from
that it's hard to pinpoint exactly how
it happened tank but the point is it
happened all right well I'm sorry but I
do thank you for doing that I'm really
looking forward to hearing more of the
stories coming out of that which you
were posting on your tumblr and and also
I I hope we'll see in a video next week
yeah Rosie Anna gave me my tumblr
password back after almost a year so
that I could so that I could sort of
share some of the stories from the
people we met I think however that she's
gonna have to go ahead and and take my
password back pretty shortly after I'm
done posting this this series of posts
but yeah you can check out my tumblr
fishing boat proceeds tumblr comm to
meet some of the people I met but yeah I
think I'm also going to be making videos
about it for the next few weeks I have
to say Hank before we start the proper
podcast and I asked you how you're doing
I made a mistake in our previous video
by saying that Franklin Delano Roosevelt
packed the court with extra Supreme
Court justices instead he just
threatened Tom's to Supreme Court just
as another place where my knowledge of
American history pretty sketchy so I
apologize now Hank how are you doing I'm
good I'm a little overwhelmed after my
vacation just catching up on everything
we just had our our scishow patreon
livestream where we increased size shows
patreon budget by more than 20% thank
you very much to all the people who
helped us out with that that's great
that's a huge part of of how we're able
to kind
keep things running around here is the
support that people show us on patreon
to scishow and crash course so that's
awesome
I was very exciting and mmin working
long long days
I shot 10 Sai shows this week Wow
which is which is a lot and I I have a
quite an intense day today that I but
after that after you know we hit 5
o'clock I will be it will be the weekend
we're recording this on Friday and I
will be able to uh not for a couple of
days I got some stuff that I'll have to
do this this weekend but I don't have
anything on the schedule and it's very
very exciting well I'm very happy for
you I hope you have a relaxing weekend
Hank would you like a short poem for the
day sure all right I picked a short poem
today from a Syrian poet nazar kobani
this is called light is more important
than the lantern it's translated by B
from is a and C Brown I don't know who
those people are but light is more
important than the lantern by nazar
kobani light is more important than the
lantern the poem more important than the
notebook and the kiss more important
than the lips my letters to you are
greater and more important than both of
us they are the only documents where
people will discover your beauty and my
madness
light is more important than the lantern
by nazar kobani that was lovely hey can
I tell you one story about my trip to
northern Jordan please do one of the
things that really struck me was that
was the separation of families you know
I've been to very poor parts of the
world before and and but I've never been
to a place where there was so much
dislocation and separation and I don't
think I ever really understood and I
certainly still don't understand but I'd
never really glimpsed before the extent
of that trauma and one of the things
that I saw over and over and over again
is that when people would talk about
their relatives who'd been
killed in the war or who were in Germany
or who were in Turkey or who were still
in Syria but but for whatever reason
that they were separated many in many
cases you know husbands and wives who'd
been separated for years brothers and
sisters who hadn't seen each other in
five years stories like that I would ask
if they had pictures of their of their
family members and I would show them
pictures of of Henry and Alice and and
Sarah and and then they would they
almost always did have pictures but they
almost never had them printed out or
backed up in any way they just had them
on on their phones sometimes in many
cases their old phones because the
pictures were so old were years old and
in the interim they've you know gotten
gotten new you know better phones and so
that I would see again and again these
pictures of family members grainy
pictures on phones that were the only
the only kind of surviving copy the only
like physical connection between aside
from memory and it was really
interesting and and moving to me that
we've moved to a place where digital
memories are sometimes the only memories
mm-hmm that is that and and that you
have these old devices that are kind of
you know unsafe places to keep these
things yeah because you never know
what's gonna happen to one of those and
you're just sort of holding holding them
and keeping them charged so that you can
continue to have access to your photos
right yeah that's the only thing that
most of the people I talked to use them
for it is to look at look at pictures to
share pictures with their young kids I
think because a lot of times you know
little kids forget they're the faces of
their of their parents or of their older
older brothers who may be in Europe or
or might have died in the war it was a
very it was a very sobering experience
for sure and and you know I hope that I
can tell some of the stories effectively
because I think it's so important to
counter the narratives about about
refugees that that that we see this sort
of xenophobic narratives that we hear a
especially in the West indeed I've got a
first question that is in reference to
that from Parker great who is working in
lesbos Greece with refugees from Syria
and Iraq and Afghanistan and so many
other places and when I call home or
post on my blog or Facebook I get a lot
of mixed reactions many of them hostile
this is probably due to the culture that
I call home the South the American South
I assume there are so many people who
have hostility towards these hurting
people and I want to help them
understand that these are not Isis
members their families who have lost so
much and are searching for a better life
any dubious advice on how to help others
emphasize empathize would be appreciated
well I do think we have a huge empathy
gap when it comes to the refugee
experience whether it's Syria Iraq
Afghanistan South Sudan wherever it is
because it's difficult for us to imagine
and also you know I asked a lot of a lot
of refugees about this while I was while
I was in Jordan you know I said what
would you say to Americans who are
concerned about Isis or concerned about
you know that you might be radical or
that you might have something against
the United States
the thing that struck me the most was
that people were not angry at the United
States at least the people I spoke to
they were very grateful because while
UNHCR the UN's refugee agency is
critically underfunded the US has
stepped up more than many countries and
and refugees are keenly aware of that so
so I found that really interesting but
what what I heard again and again was
people people saying you know you're
right there are like there are in Syria
and Iraq members of Isis who wish
destruction upon me which is why I'm not
in Syria anymore which is why I had to
leave you know and especially I heard
this especially from young men because I
told every time I had a chance to talk
to you know an adult like a
say 20 to 35 year-old adult man I said
you know one of the things that we hear
a lot in the United States is that is is
that this is no longer true but it used
to be true that most of the refugees
coming to Europe were were adult men and
how do you feel about people saying you
should be in Iraq in Iraq or in Syria
fighting Isis or fighting for your
country's freedom and their response was
that's not how it worked you know how it
worked was you were conscripted into an
army that does not reflect your belief
or your value system under punishment of
death or murder of your family members
it's not a question of you know like
fighting for freedom it's a question of
not being conscripted into an army
that's trying to you know that that that
if you don't go they'll they'll kill
people in your family and and the truth
is that while there have been crimes
committed by asylum seekers in Europe
and while there have been crimes
committed by refugees in the u.s. in the
past not Syrian refugees so far as I
know but it has it has happened their
crimes and they should be prosecuted as
crimes and they should not be seen as
reflective of some entire community the
same way that I wouldn't want the
actions of the young white man who
murdered people in an african-american
church while they were at worship to be
reflective of me as a white person so we
have to prosecute crimes as crimes and
not as reflective of some you know
larger failure of an entire people yeah
as we get deeper into this election
season it's gonna be harder and harder
not to talk about politics and to think
about these things in the in the lens of
of the the election here in America
because it's very difficult for me not
to immediately think of you know the
implications and sort of like how this
works psychologically which is that we
are prone to being afraid of things that
we don't understand if people we don't
understand if people who are different
from us and even in
always even if those differences are
quite small and and that in order the
best way to get support as a candidate
is to make people afraid that's what
gets people more than any other emotion
that's what gets people to take actions
and even if that act if that action is
to get up and go vote then fear is is a
great motivator and I'm seeing more and
more of this it's not really about any
legitimate credible scary thing
there are scary things that happen but
of course there are lots of lots of
different ways that people get hurt and
injured and have their lives become
worse and you know it we're not
particularly good at judging those
threats as humans that we are really
good at being afraid of other people who
we see as not like us or who we see
might be trying to take advantage of us
or or worse and that fear-mongering is
so much more powerful than hope
mongering then then thinking about like
feeling the connection between all
humans and knowing that that these
people more than anyone in the world
need help right now and and it's very
unpleasant to watch how the conversation
is progressing in America so as far as
Parker's actual question goes I I don't
even know I just hope that people can
find fear to be not the emotion to grasp
on to and to and to make such an
important part of how they see the world
yeah Parker the only thing that I would
say in addition to that is to keep
telling these people's stories because
they don't have access to the same
platforms that you do in most cases in
most cases they can't write in English
in most cases they don't have you know
they're kind of internet access that
allows them to tell their own stories so
you know quote their stories tell their
stories share their
stories and many people will react
negatively to that many people will
doubt your sincerity or their sincerity
but at least it gives them something of
a voice in this conversation because I
think one of the biggest problems right
now is that we hear a lot about what
Donald Trump thinks of Islam but not a
lot about what Muslims think of Islam
and so I think just share those stories
and keep up your your good work yeah
we're grateful for it yeah Thank You
Parker and thank you John for for
helping share those stories and helping
us you know helping us bridge that
empathy gap we have another question
this one is from Miss D who asks dear
Hank and John it's a little it's a
problem but it is a smaller problem I'm
a middle school teacher and I love my
students my biggest complaint I have
about them as they leave a trail of half
empty water bottles behind them wherever
they go there are currently three half
empty water bottles in my room right now
and I try to encourage reusable water
bottles with their name written in
sharpie but there are just 11 years old
and they have whatever their parents
send them to school with I feel bad not
just about the waste of plastic but the
water I drink a lot of tea and I'm
really tempted to just put all that
extra water I find into a my electric
tea kettle and boil the heck out of it
and then make make will that get rid of
all the child germs or should I just
find a plant to water them with I mean
as someone who currently has a probable
case of dysentery I'm the client to get
the plant misty yeah I mean I first of
all if you do if you boil the water and
make tea out of it it will indeed kill
those weird child germs but you to kill
all of them I'm not really concerned
about you killing all of them because I
think probably none of your children in
class have cholera but I you yeah you
might still get sick isn't it unless you
boil it for like 10 minutes or something
which is just energy-efficient and you
don't want that yeah as long as you boil
it for five to ten minutes you should
actually be fine and that's coming from
someone who's
you know a little bit cautious on these
topics but I think it's fine in theory
there's just something about it just
yeah and also I think if your end up
boiling that water for longer than usual
the energy that you're using to do that
is probably going to offset any any
energy you save by saving the water but
I the other thing I'd say is get that is
so annoying it and it is annoying for me
because of the plastic not because of
the water you know obviously the water
waste is something but it is not
substantial and if they drink it they
probably wouldn't get that much out of
it anyway they probably just peel a
little more next time they went to the
bathroom but I I mean I know a guy who
will go nameless who leaves half-empty
bottles of diet dr. pepper all over the
world and I find it a little bit
frustrating it is yeah it is to be
laughs did you just open why did you
just open a new bottle of diet dr.
pepper when there is clearly one right
there that is half empty I mean they
just taste so great when they're fresh
there's just nothing like that first sip
of a diet dr. pepper oh my god of which
Hank what what do I have to do to get
sponsored by diet dr. pepper I am the
greatest spokesperson they have ever had
I don't know John maybe someone
listening is in the marketing department
at dr. pepper enterprises which is I
believe by the way I'm enjoying a
delicious diet dr. pepper right now I'm
sure you are I believe that dr. pepper
is a separate company from Pepsi and
Coke is that correct that is correct yes
they are their own antifreeze nothing
like diet dr. pepper it's unique in the
world
yeah that's very interesting you know
diet you know dr. pepper has its own
bottled water there's like Aquafina and
Dasani are the Pepsi and Coke ones and
then but then there's a separate Dr
Pepper bottled water which I ran into in
a in a airport when I was thirsty
and and I felt bad about it don't worry
but I did not have my reusable water
bottle with me but yeah III I think that
you should I think that you should take
an entire lesson out of the of your week
and just uh you know pack
the other four days full of of the stuff
you would normally teach on that
Wednesday and then on Wednesday you say
we're gonna have a special class and
today we're going to talk about reuse
and recycling and and how how the future
generations will see us as the most
profligate wasteful bunch of turds that
ever existed on the surface of the
planet and how how did we squander our
wonderful wonderful level of excess that
we had in America in the 21st century
oh by tossing water bottles when they
were half-empty that's that's your
lecture for you rub it all in their
11-year old face and make them feel that
guilt oh man our comedy podcast finally
got briefly funny ok Hank we've got
another question this one comes from
Nick who writes dear Hank John if
understand what me say when speak
English bad why need speak English good
you know this is a great question and I
wasn't anything about it I was thinking
about a lot lousy ting breakfast and
reading these questions and you know
honestly I think a lot of the reason is
how much information we pack not into
just what we say but but how we say it
and I don't mean like how you say it
like get up there and be a good public
speaker I mean the way that we talk says
a lot like it is a way that we judge
each other and so I'm not saying that
this is a good thing I'm saying that it
is it is a thing that when we speak
correctly people think more highly of us
I would agree except that I would say
that there is no such a cruel thing as
speaking correct as correctly that yes
if we speak in a certain way that sounds
like the way that yes writes that
sentence by the way was undying credit
so my argument about this Nick is that I
understood what you meant when in your
question but it wasn't as clear to me as
quickly as it would have been if you'd
said if people understand me when I when
I speak English poorly why should I
speak English well and so for me
grammar and and language is not only
about like overall comprehension it's
also about the speed at which that
comprehension can happen because that
means that we can have sort of a more
transparent conversation like language
ultimately should be completely
transparent in my opinion at least it
should just it should just be sort of
the the soundwaves through which ideas
travel between people and every time we
make that less clear or we make it in
some way opaque we're doing damage to
the quality of conversation that you and
I can have together and so that's my
argument for if not grammatically
correct English or the King's English or
whatever at least a shared agreed-upon
English that in the end is all I think
that really matters is that we agree
upon like what language what kind of
language choices were gonna make so that
when we have conversations or when we're
reading we can do so with clear I don't
want to I don't want to spend too much
time on this question but but what about
like the way that people create new
languages like if we say that like we
want maximum clarity then what we're
saying is we want one Universal
structured English that is all the same
and everybody speaks the same English
but what does that take away from new
versions of English or accented English
Azure you know like new ways well no I
don't think we want one version of
English that everyone speaks because I
don't think that we necessarily want
everyone to understand us when we're
speaking right so like I think there are
that's one of the reasons that we change
language is so that people won't
understand
people who we don't want to understand
us won't understand it's another reason
we change language and I think this is a
very cool and interesting reason is
because the language that exists does
not do a good job of describing our
experience and so we can we can create
words or phrases that will do a better
job and that will all sort of
immediately under store or you know a
certain group anyway will immediately
understands right the meaning of because
it just sounds right or it feels right
or whatever so I'm not against in any
way I'm not opposed to language changing
I think it should change but but I think
it should be you know as transparent as
possible when you're having a
conversation alright we've got another
question is from Jordi Kahoot asks dear
Hank and John
Hank believes that you can i but that
you can learn a lot about someone by
their favorite bridge I think the way a
person's house smells says a lot fess up
what's the smelling in your dwelling
Hank only ask that question because he
liked the rhyme at the end well yes
partially I think that I think that
there is a lovely thing about a
well-constructed question that has a
nice little rhyme but also I wanted to
talk about death for this question
because the smelling in mind Welling is
very depressingly non smelly because mut
because it's not full of dog farts
anymore John I walk in every day and I'm
like I like not only is there not a
happy waggy thing there to say hey
there's also not that smell
never that smell yeah it is funny I mean
the people and animals in your house
sort of make up the the way you smell it
and when it doesn't smell like that it
doesn't feel like your house I'm sorry
about that Hank I don't know what the
smelling in my house is precisely
because it's the smell in my house but I
know if it changes so I'm sure that if I
walked in and and Willie suddenly
weren't there I would I would sense his
absence or in an olfactory manner and so
it's weird not something that you'd
think about until it's not there but
yeah my house my house does not smell a
great deal it's fairly fairly new but I
go back to Florida and I'm like
everything smells like mold and then my
face starts to explode because
apparently I didn't realize how allergic
I was to mold until I left Florida and
was like oh I can breathe wonderful oh
man
Florida it's so Florida II it's so
Florida II all right we have another
question this one comes from Mary who
writes dear John and Hank some people
have for whatever reason started to
believe
that the earth is actually flat after
years of evidence suggesting in his
round not just years really millennia
really longer than millennia really
billions of years of evidence exists
thing that it is round
obviously the earth is round I strongly
agree Mary I'm glad that we could start
from that point but it got me wondering
what would life be like if the earth
were flat how would it be different and
just so you can mention death in the
podcast would we all die
thanks for the opportunity to mention
death Mary of course we would all die
yes yes we would all die if the earth
were flat we would all die in the
process of it becoming round what well
yeah because if you had a flat earth it
would like if you had the the mass of
the earth stretched out at a flat disk
or whatever shape you want it would
coalesce via gravity it would break
apart and form a sphere oh yeah so we
would all die everything would die and
then the earth would have to reform and
then you'd have to go through all 4.5
billion years of the Earth's history
before you had anything even approaching
the in earth at the level of
interestingness of this podcast so so
that's what would happen all right Hank
are you at all fascinated by conspiracy
theories along the lines of the earth is
actually flat or do you just find them
ludicrous or like or like there's the or
there's the Cyberman earth on the other
side of the Sun that's just matching our
orbit and we never can see it oh no
that's real I believe that planet has a
name but I can't remember its name it
was I think it was milori and meloria of
course yeah meloria is real we just
can't see it
yeah I I you know there there is one
that I am kind of fascinated by it's
called the shadow microbiome no the
shadow the shadow biosphere the shadow
biosphere that's what it's called okay
and it's the idea that there is a whole
other biosphere on earth that we do not
know about and can't detect because it
doesn't use the same chemistry as the
life that we know about so is this idea
basically that like if we if we go to
Mars life could be so different that we
wouldn't even know it existed because
none of the systems we use for testing
for life would
work on it and so so if that's possible
then why isn't there a possibility that
here on earth there are a bunch of
microorganisms that don't have
mitochondria they don't use DNA they
don't use any of the same proteins we
use and so when we do tests to see if
there are living things we're like well
nothing there but maybe there is
something alive there it's just so
different that we cannot tell that
there's a living thing there now I don't
think that this is actually a thing that
is real I don't think this is that the
shadow MicroBot the shadow of Io I don't
think that the shadow biosphere is real
I think that it like there is a tiny
tiny tiny chance that it could be and
that is fascinating well but this would
just be microscopic organisms right this
wouldn't be really yes
no I mean it's Asian there were like
shadow dogs a shadow shadow biosphere
that had like dogs in it we would see
that okay they would reflect they would
they would still absorb and reflect
light right so just to confirm here what
you're telling me is that it's possible
that in addition to half of my body
being bacteria another half of my body
could be organisms that I just don't
know our life yeah the good news is they
really probably could not do any damage
to you if they were based on completely
different chemistry they would see you
as maybe a source of water maybe a
source of warmth but but it would be
very difficult for them to interact with
any of your any of your biological
systems because of how different they
would be can I tell you my favorite
conspiracy theory all right go
there is a conspiracy theory on the
internet you can google it that Stephen
Hawking the theoretical physicist mm-hmm
was replaced by a different Stephen
Hawking in about 1985 that's real weird
and there are lots and lots and lots of
people who believe it and the amount of
research that they have done into it is
horrifying and it's just a very strange
corner of the internet I'm always
fascinated by the strange corners of the
internet if not always encouraged by
them but that is one of the stranger
ones I have come across this this
podcast John is brought to you by shadow
Stephen Hawking shadows Steven Hauk
introduced to the world in 1983 or at 89
or whatever you said to be a new and
better Steven Hauk and of course this
podcast is brought to you by delicious
diet dr. pepper diet dr. pepper I want
you to sponsor me this podcast is also
brought to you by tea made from the
leavings of eleven-year-old schnapps tea
made from the leavings of
eleven-year-olds knots good for you
good for the environment and almost
certainly not gonna give you dysentery
and of course this podcast is brought to
you by the Flat Earth the Flat Earth
unfortunately coalescing into a sphere
killing us all no better part of the
podcast John that's really it's really
what everybody's waiting for that and
then they all leave for sure well done
well done alright John we got there are
so many good questions today there are
so many good questions we've got one
here from ash who asks dear Hank and
John I have a very urgent question I'm
wondering why don't bugs die when we
flick them they are sick we are
significantly larger and stronger than
the bugs and can crush them with a
finger yet somehow the impact of a flick
does not kill them can you explain these
superhero insects to me I cannot but I
bet Hank can I can I can basically i if
lick flicks something really small the
bug size like a piece of crust which I
have on my desk which I just flicked and
then flick your desk flick something
hard that's not gonna move you will feel
a difference between the thing that
happened to your finger you will feel
that the flicking of the flee of the of
the piece of dust did not hurt the
flicking you don't even want to do it do
you're like I'm not gonna flick on
something hard so what's happening is
you know force which is the thing that's
gonna kill the bug is mass times
acceleration and when you are pushing on
a bug your mass the amount of math that
you are transferring is is gigantic when
you're flicking a bug the only mass
involved isn't the mass of you it's the
mass of the bug which is very small now
if you flick a big bug if you flick like
a tarantula and the face don't do that
or you flick like a real like a horse
fly you could kill you could kill that
bug because it's like flicking something
from something hard and big and you're
gonna transfer all of that kinetic
energy into the bug whereas and into the
mass of that bug so you're gonna get a
large force but if you're flicking like
a gnat or something then that force is
very small because the mass of the gnat
is very small which allows them to live
through very significant changes in
acceleration well that is just
fascinating I'm so grateful for this
lesson in physics alright I I do I do
have another one that I wanted to get to
which is from grace grace asks dear Hank
and John over the last few years I've
gained a greater confidence in myself
however my family has increasingly begun
to refer to this confidence as
narcissism how do I sustain this
confidence without becoming narcissistic
is narcissism necessarily a bad thing
and if so where is the line between
confidence in one's self and narcissism
any advice especially dubious advice
which would be much appreciated oh man
yeah that's a difficult question I think
ultimately if people are telling you
that you have a problem with narcissism
you should probably listen to them I
mean I don't think that I don't think
that confidence and narcissism are
mutually exclusive do you Hank no I I do
think that they are different things
they lie I'll be off to the die but yeah
that's what I was thinking about this
question all morning because I because
there's this there's such we we need
this we need to feel valued and valuable
to be humans but at the same time there
is definitely this thing where I really
don't like people who feel that in a way
and like have the source of that be
something that I find unpleasant and I
think that that a lot of times
narcissism is in fact when the source of
your confidence
is either I think in the best case
scenario it's something that you don't
like people see is something you don't
deserve so if you are very powerful and
wealthy and you are you feel very
confident because of your wealth then
then it's like well did but you were
just you know you were just born wealthy
then that's very strange that's like
saying I'm better than other people
because I have this thing that other
people don't have and and maybe there's
maybe there's an element of that like
easier confidence in like you were being
better than other people or is your
confidence in comparison to you and how
you feel you are and you you like
achieving for yourself what you feel
like are the right things for a person
to be and I think that that confidence
is is a wonderful thing but that means
that confidence and being humble are not
like are like are completely like you
can be both of those things at the same
time whereas yeah I think that there's a
way to be confident and also to be so
confident that you're kind of reveling
in it and maybe reveling in a kind of
confidence in a thing that you babe
maybe aren't even responsible for that
it can be really off-putting to people I
think that was a great answer Hank I'm
not going to try to add to it I do
however want to answer one more question
before we get to the news from Mars a
cold dead Rock in space and AFC
Wimbledon the greatest achievement in
the history of human cannot I cannot
believe it's time for that already a cat
already this question comes from Rachel
who asks Dear John and Hank why is it
that whenever money is shown on TV or in
the movies it is so obviously fake not
just large amounts but even single
dollar bills I can understand not
wanting to use real money on set but it
seems to me like the props Department
goes out of its way to make the money
not look real so I think that you might
actually be mistaken because sometimes I
have seen real money used on movie sets
in Paper Towns they use you know money
just like a couple dollar bills when
it's one dollar bills I think they tend
to use real money when it's large
amounts of money they do use fake money
and do you want to know why they use
fake money Hank
because it's hard to get a bunch of
money
that is incorrect okay oh wait no that
is correct but do you want to know why
the money is obviously fake no because
you cannot get because it is illegal to
have accurate looking fake money that is
right and in 2000 when a big-budget
movie blew up a billion dollars worth of
$100 fake bills and sent them flying
everywhere people used them because they
were very compelling and there passed
them off as legitimate and then the
Secret Service arrested the props master
who will created the bill so as you can
imagine people who work in Hollywood not
anxious to be arrested these days make
the money look pretty fake wow that's
fascinating I mean you'd think maybe
they'd just make the backs look fake
like not print anything on the back so
if they're not gonna bet maybe I don't
know that's that's really cool there's a
there's a possible other explanation
here which is that maybe you're watching
old movies when money looked different
yeah that's a great point because it
wasn't so long ago that American Bills
looked very different and yet we
continued to print them all the exact
same size which is opening
discriminatory toward blind people we
can make all kinds of different changes
but for some reason we refuse to make
that one also we continue to make
pennies which is whoo - Chris okay we're
gonna do one more question John but
we're gonna do it after the news from
Mars and AFC 1 but we're gonna shake up
the format a little bit here so
basically I'm trying to do is force
people to listen to the news from Mars
and AFC Wimbledon this last question is
gonna be a doozy - so you've got a stay
yeah it's got to be so good John did a
bunch of research for it what's the news
from Mars Hank the news from Mars is
some new information about the Mars is
ancient history now John you know that
Mars has the largest volcano in the
solar system I did know that
no I didn't you've got Olympus Mons
which is the biggest volcano ever and
then you have a few other very large
volcanoes that are very small compared
to them
but still freakin gigantic and around
three billion to 3.5 billion years ago
is when these volcanoes first started
erupting now they are still potentially
still erupting even to this day now the
most recent eruption of Olympus Mons
very small eruption happened like less
than a hundred thousand years ago which
geologic time not a long time so it's
possible that there are still eruptions
to come but back three three billion to
3.5 billion years ago now when this
these these volcanoes were forming a
remarkable thing happened where they
were so massive they made the they made
Mars like lopsided and the entire planet
shifted around its its core so I command
like like you put your fist over your
fist and you move you're fit that's what
happened like Mars stayed in the same
place but the surface of Mars shifted
around does that make sense
hopefully that makes sense this means
that when we're looking at the surface
of Mars we're not looking at how it was
always oriented that it actually has has
slipped and so if you are thinking about
like how Martian seasons were four
billion years ago they were different
than they are now
now of course that was all very long ago
probably before any life could have
formed on Mars before you know like
before any of the of the features that
we see on Mars that may have been that
are relating to water existed so we're
not of course we don't know what Mars
looked like three point seven billion
years ago but it's pretty cool that we
can tell this one thing about the
history of Mars that happened so very
long ago
it is fascinating you know what I find
even more fascinating is that the earth
is actually flat yeah well only for a
little bit we better we better we can
okay I am excited to move on to the news
from AFC Wimbledon Hank because I was
actually at AFC Wimbledon's game against
Oxford United I got to meet manager Neil
Ardley
first team coach Simon bassy I got to
meet all the players Hank I went into
the locker room before the game and
shook hands that's four to go up with
every single every single player from
the team including autobuyer walk and
well I told Lyle Taylor that we called
him the montserrat e and Messi and he
looked briefly confused because of
course he is not actually from
Montserrat he's from England but because
he has a grandparent for Montserrat he
plays for the Montserrat national team
but he seemed quite pleased with the
nickname I told Calum Kennedy that that
Meredith the producer of the AFC
wimbledon wimbly Wobblies is a big fan
of his and he was delighted I got it was
so fun to meet all of the players and
the atmosphere it must be said at the
stadium was just amazing the John Green
Stand was packed it was sold out there
was singing it was wonderful Andy Barr
Cheam scored a goal for Wimbledon and
they lost two to one hahaha that's too
bad
cos Oxford's right there at the top of
the table that's right Oxford's up there
at the top of the table but then we
played league leading Northampton next
who our way at the top of the table
there 11 points clear and we tied them
1-1 so we took one point away from that
game at Northampton which is really a
pretty important pretty important point
it must be said and you know while it
would have been ideal to win that game
against Oxford and put what that would
have put us in a position potentially
where we could have I don't know maybe
you know maybe ended up in those top
three spots that are automatically
promoted that isn't you know that isn't
how it happened
instead we lost that game which was a
bummer right so yeah probably it's it's
there it's a it'd be a real hard fight
to get up in those top three spots now
it's looking like we're not going to get
up in those top three spots at this
point so what we have instead is to get
into one of the spots between four and
seven so we can get into the playoffs
and maybe get promoted that way it's
it's gonna be difficult right now we are
eighth with 52 points but the team that
is fifth only has 53 points so it should
be possible I should add
hanck that Wimbledon's crucial tying
goal against league-leading Northampton
was scored by none other than the
Montserrat II and Messi Lyell Taylor
who's just had a fantastic season for us
so we are currently in eighth which
means that we are missing out on the
playoffs but only one point away from
fifth unfortunately 12 points away from
the automatic promotion spot that is
third place so that's looking unlikely
with just 13 games to go but hope is the
thing with feathers Hank hope is the
thing with feathers all right well I've
got some notes here we're gonna put
we're gonna start putting podcast notes
up on up on dear Hank and up on the dear
Hank and John patreon so you will be
able to see some of the things that we
talked about and the thing that I want
to show you this week in our podcast
notes is from Kyla who says looks like
somebody already beat me to it so you
know that there are feral cows in Hong
Kong however I bet you didn't know that
they enjoyed pumpkin spice cliff bars I
visited Hong Kong a couple weeks ago and
have attached some photos for your
enjoyment the cows are on new Gong Ngong
ping Island
I don't speak this language and the cows
wander around but are kept out of the
vicinity of the monastery and the the
Big Buddha that they have there and I
may have accidentally led a stampede of
feral cows as they followed me looking
for more cliff cliff bars and petting
but I don't regret it says Kyla so we're
gonna post some of Kyle's pictures of
feral cows in Hong Kong and then we also
have hake can I confirm that you can you
can visit all of that stuff on the
patreon even if you don't support us on
patreon right that is absolutely true at
which I was going to mention in
reference to Tim's question who says
dear Hank and John one quick question
concerning the podcast where are we
supposed to discuss the podcast or
rather is there a place on the internet
where the podcast is discussed and can I
join you can there's conversations going
on on the SoundCloud which is where we
post dear Hank and John on for Internet
viewership and it is also there are
conversations happening on the patreon
now you don't have to be a patron patron
to join the conversation on patreon and
we encourage you to do that
and I hope that there are interesting
conversations going on there which is
where we have our podcast notes and also
we'll be able to listen to the podcast
there yeah so basically if you had at
patreon.com slash dear Hank and John you
have the option to support our podcast
here and help out Nick who edits the
show and Claudia our intern but you
don't really have to you get 99% of the
benefits just by going to the webpage
you can see everything the only thing
that you don't have access to is our
monthly live stream which frankly is of
exceptionally low quality nonetheless we
appreciate all of your support on
patreon it it really helps out with the
show so thank you but but you don't need
to support the podcast financially to
see all of the stuff that we post on the
dear Hank and John patreon alright and
now we have our final question which
comes from Shelby dear Hank and John
given its varying price points
throughout the world how much in USD
would it actually cost to buy the world
a coke I mean this is an exceptionally
difficult question to answer so one of
the reasons that this is such a
difficult question to answer is that
you've got to count whether or not
different municipalities charge extra
for you to return on the can like you
get a five cent or ten cent refund you
know mm hmm hmm yeah and then you got
soda taxes in some places in America
you're not gonna get an exact number
could we get a you're not gonna get an
exact number but what I have seen is
that there is a website called who much
com and it says that the global average
price of one can of coca-cola is two
dollars and sixty-five cents
what for 12 ounces for three hundred and
thirty milliliters I think that this is
wrong
I also think this is wrong Hank you also
think that it is wrong yeah because
that's not how much it kind of coke
costs yeah I think that it is wrong
because it says that in the United
States the price is $4 and
three cents yeah that seems pretty wrong
so I think we've got a lot of like wrong
answers that have that have messed up
whoo much calm my theory is that a can
of coke because I based this on having
traveled to four countries so this is a
very round estimate okay but I just
bought a can of Pepsi at the as rock
refugee camp in northern Jordan I've
purchased a can of coke in Addis Ababa
Ethiopia I've purchased coke in the
Dominican Republic in Mexico in the
United States in Canada none of these
places by the way have died Dr Pepper
except with any place in Canada or else
I wouldn't have purchased a coke believe
me and I'm going to say that the average
price of a coke on earth is 75 cents
that is my round guess like just buying
one coke obviously if you if you buy 12
cokes at a time yeah you get a bulk
discount but I think the average price
for one coke is around 75 cents you
think that's - hi Hank
well I think if you're gonna buy the
world a coke you're gonna get a bulk
discount okay let's assume that we get a
bulk discount in that case a 12-pack is
like three bucks and 12 / Thea I'm gonna
say I'm gonna say 25 I'm gonna say if we
are gonna try and buy seven billion
cokes we can get a pretty steep discount
so I'm gonna I'm gonna say 25 cents and
I'm gonna say that's okay so let's say
it's 25 cents there's currently well
what is the world's current population
world's current population Google says
the world's current population is seven
point one two five billion that's a very
round number that's at most correct
within the nearest million but whatever
we're doing our best here so we're gonna
say seven point one two five billion
times point two five you could buy the
world a coke for my goodness that is a
lot of money around one point eight
billion dollars one point seven eight
billion dollars will buy you
well we'll buy the world a can of coke a
piece however are we gonna say that
maybe we don't want to buy cokes for the
babies and we'll leave it at that job by
cokes especially for the babies I don't
I think I think we should should lop off
everyone under the age of six
let's just not let's just say leave that
up for their parents actually Hank
there's something that you haven't
considered at all that neither of us
have considered and that I'm not even
sure the question considered which is
that if we're going to say how much
would it actually cost to buy the world
a coke why are we limiting the access of
coke only to one particular species it's
true John it's true if you gotta buy a
coke for every single ant then you're
gonna run out of money real fast well
the nice thing about ants though is that
they don't need like one coke a piece
you know like 500 million of them can
can use one coke right share a coke yeah
yeah just pour just just pour one out on
the hill and they'll be like that's
scary and then they'll be like no it's
not and they'll end up like dying in the
syrup of the coke but oh what a death
yet Shelby sounds about right John
alright alright Hank what did we learn
today oh yeah we learned that that uh
the coca-cola company will not sponsor
us but not because we don't well not
because they don't want to because we
don't want them to because we want Diet
Dr Pepper to sponsor us that's right
it's diet dr. pepper or nobody and of
course we learned that the earth is
round and that if it weren't it would
become round we learned that someone
once went to jail for making a movie
prop that looked too realistic it's
actually I'm not sure they went to jail
that might be like me talking about FDR
packing the court but but the Secret
Service came calling and of course we
learned that bugs don't die when we
flick them because of f equaling MA
that's correct
thank you John for podcasting with me
today thank you all of you people who
listened
the podcast today our podcast is edited
by Nicholas Jenkins our intern is
Claudia Morales rosianna halse rojas
helps us with the questions Thanks to
everyone for listening and as we sell
wait you can email us write your
questions please email them to Hank and
John at gmail.com or use the hashtag
dear Hank and John on Twitter where I'm
John Green and Hank is Hank green thanks
again for listening and as we say in our
hometown don't forget to be awesome
[Music]